bonjour monsieur la commande elle et sur
le sac sur mon siège
voilà par rapport au sans contact c'est
brut 1 qui file - si si vous posez des
questions c'est brut 1 passez une bonne
journée monsieur ben bonne soirée du
mois bon appétit
je fais ça avec tout le monde
tout le monde commence à nous au monde
fort et ça nous permet aussi de pas de
contaminer parce qu'avec les boutons les
digicodes les portes on sait jamais quoi
je râle et j'aurais aimé mon écoute et
le président de la république est
confiné avec ma femme qui est enceinte
mais malheureusement je peux pas est
dans une période de confinement comcom
comme celle là pourtant personne devrait
être dehors mais nous on n'a pas le
choix si demain on va pas travailler
n'ont rien à manger du tout ça veut dire
on aura pas d'argent pour nourrir notre
famille
[Musique]
vraiment la sensation de 16 bon alors
exactement ont simplement exactement
[Musique]
vas-y bien vu sa déchéance car son
niveau
brut comme tu as pu le voir c'est du
grand n'importe quoi est ce que tu as vu
les distances de sécurité ou pour un non
t'as rien t'as vu c'est du grand
n'importe quoi
oui bonjour monsieur ses courses et des
libéraux je suis en bas de chez vous
voilà merci bien monsieur a tout de
suite en fin de compte je vais pas vous
mentir ça un service récréatif
ça veut dire en fin de compte n'est pas
dans la nécessité d'avoir un burger ou
une pizza livrée par des livreurs par
nous les pôles vivre livreur de des
libéraux de gilbert tu vois au final si
plus récréatif ça veut dire c'est pour
le loisir le plaisir des gens pour qui
pour qu'ils vivent mieux leur
confinement et bas nous on est là pour
eux et ça veut dire en fin de compte on
enlève leurs plans
[Musique]
pour y aller ah ben voilà
ah ouais tu regardes avant dans paris
mais les nuls ben tiens regarde cette
approche l'écran cette commande là à
l'époque elle était payée minimum 10
euros là tu vas juste 1 rue d'anjou pour
7 euros 35 me casse les prix
ça veut dire non seulement il n'y a pas
de travail mais non seulement ils
cassent les prix allez on l'apprend
c'est la laisser porter par logis pour
clichy 6 0 44 ça reste la banlieue haut
niveau à l'ego mon reste positive comme
audi n'ont pas choix sportif
[Musique]